ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier unserer kleinen süßen minecraft
welt in meine lieben freunde ihr seht
schon wir befinden uns noch immer in der
höhle
das ist auch mein plan für die heutige
episode meine lieben freunde von daher
kommen wir nun tatsächlich zur frühesten
time labs aller zeiten dies in diesem
projekt bisher jemals gab
denn mir wurde häufig in die kommentare
geschrieben und letzte episode hey luca
du hast schon insgesamt 34 diamant die
seht ihr ja unten eingeblendet bei lukas
hier auf ne das soll besser so ihr seht
schon unten ich hab ja insgesamt 34
diamanten von daher würde ich sagen
blende ich euch ganz kurz mal eine
timeline wie ich alle ärzte noch
mitnehmen die wir gefunden haben und
dann wie wir dann hoffentlich wieder
nach oben gehen
das ist nicht wahr ich habe einfach
gerade 20 minuten lang erz abgebaut und
jetzt ist hier plötzlich wieder
einnehmen schafft wie kann es denn sein
dass wir so ein verdammtes glück in
unserer welt haben
ich hab nicht mal ansatzweise aller
ärzte mitgenommen die ich vorhin überall
gesehen habe aber jetzt ist hier wieder
ein minenschacht
[Musik]
ich nehme schon wieder seit eineinhalb
stunden auf und mein apple watch sagt
mir gerade es ist zeit aufzustehen und
sich eine minute zu bewegen
darauf jetzt erstmal eine
dreiviertelstunde ärzte abbauen
[Musik]
scheiße ich habe gerade zombies bonner
entdeckt oder
ja es ist ein zombies bonner wir haben
in den kisten fehlerfall 4 und die
andere kiste existiert sogar gar nicht
die sache allerdings fixiert mir da
unten auch schon wieder in krippe haben
ich bin in meiner aufnahme bei 2 stunden
es hat sich gerade etwas krasses
herausgestellt denn ich habe endlich ich
weiß nicht ob ich denn jetzt irgendwo
hier wo ist ja ich war ziemlich lange
weg ich habe mir allerdings gedacht und
hier ist immer noch unfassbar viel
vorhanden überall
ich habe auch einige meiner bases als
ich hab mir wirklich in den ganzen tag
im netz das jetzt drei bases gemacht die
habe ich alle wieder verloren und ihr
könnt euch trotzdem angucken was ich
alles habe ich habe viele das sind alles
blockener kohleblöcke habe ich vier
stück ich habe einen halben redstone
blocken lapislazuli blog goldpreisen
blöcke hier habe ich noch reisen reisen
bei lewis hier am start es gibt ganz
viele gänge wo ich noch gar nicht lange
gegangen mit lassen zombie wieder am
start die sache ist allerdings dass ich
hier
ich will halt eigentlich sollte zwecks
hier weil du macht da keine scheiße ball
und schilder mit dem keeper
wer euch nicht weh tun da vorne ich bin
nur den keeper töten
er möge letztlich muss man mit pfeil und
bogen auf jeden fall arbeiten
die sache ist ich will eigentlich noch
die durch die höhle laufen und alles
mitnehmen an gold an
hier seht ihr auch schon wieder kohle
und eisen weil wir das dann handeln
können mit unseren sinnen und dadurch
bekommen wir das markt und ihr seht auch
schon hier ist balu ihr seht auch schon
wie viel hier wirklich noch unentdeckt
ist in der höhle
die sache ist allerdings dass wir
wirklich keine zeit mehr dafür haben hey
baby ist tot
wir haben wirklich keine zeit dafür ich
will so viel eigentlich noch machen in
der heutigen folge das ist die große
tipp folge eigentlich und zwar wollte
ich oft eine ganz ganz ganz ganz große
menge an kommentaren eingehen die ich
mir alle vorher ausgesucht habe von
wegen harry luca mach mal dies in einer
weltmacht mal dass sie hat mir ihr
schreibt mir mehr unzählige tipps und in
die kommentare
die sache ist allerdings dass ich hier
wirklich alles mitnehmen möchte an kohle
et cetera pp damit wir alles verdienen
können mit den villingern so dass wir es
mal ab bekommen mit den smaragden können
arbeiter tauschen und diamant items
bekommen von daher würde ich sagen wir
machen noch eine allerletzte teilnetz
und dann sehen wir uns wenn ich wieder
oben bin
[Musik]
wir haben nochmal diamanten gefunden
freunde ich habe euch jetzt doch noch
mal keine details eingeblendet weil das
hier erst zwei minuten später passiert
ist was jetzt nicht gewohnt aber wir
haben wirklich nochmal diamanten
gefunden
ihr seht und ich habe 30 diamanten das
sind kann es einfach daran also ich habe
vier stück schon verloren
diese nicht verloren sondern ich musste
meine spitzhacke ein bisschen reparieren
dafür braucht nur ein blog ist nicht
dein ernst oder nur ein diamant
blockieren kompletten umfeld oder was er
gut denn jetzt noch mal ganz kurz ein
teil im labs
[Musik]
mord
ich hab mir gern augentropfen
eingeschaltet ich bin bei fast drei
stunden ich bin die ganze zeit und in
der höhle ich habe eine base
wiedergefunden hier brutzeln auf jeden
fall grad noch ein paar sachen und ich
habe auch hier noch deutlich mehr an
staat bekommen ich werde ihr seht mich
gerade nicht das total verrückt und
jetzt werde ich mal ganz kurz denn so
lange habe ich noch nie aufgenommen es
ist für euch wahrscheinlich gerade mal 1
minute 3 oder 2 oder so aber noch eine
wirklich mühe talk aller allerletzte
tablets wie ich versuche noch zwei der
verlorenen bases zu finden um dann nach
endlich die höhle zu verlassen
oh mein gott wir haben es endlich
geschafft meine lieben freunde ihr seht
schon ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet
uns hier in unserer kleinen süßen
minecraft welt
[Musik]
ein wunderschöner morgen erwartet uns
hier in unserer kleinen sitzen microsoft
hält um meine lieben freunde zum ersten
mal kann ich das heute auch mit
entspannender musik sagen ihr seht schon
da vorne unseren schatten hallo wir
haben da vorne ein skelett was sich mit
dem prügel ich freue mich so wieder hier
oben zu sein
ich habe sowas von viele sachen
mitnehmen können und ich bin ganz
ehrlich zwischenzeitlich habe ich mir
gedacht mensch lohnt sich das überhaupt
diese ganzen sachen mitzunehmen ich
möchte einfach nur nach hause
ich bin bei fast drei stunden
aufnahmezeit und eigentlich sollte das
heute die riesige tipp folge werden in
der ihr mir tipps geben konnte in den
letzten folgen bzw
das hat ja immer gemacht fast jedes
video hat fünfstellige kommentare also
wirklich der absolute knaller supporter
welcher mensch sagt knaller
ich sollte vielleicht mal ganz kurz nur
wenige minuten später ich habe vorhin
mal ganz kurz meine komplette aufnahme
das heer geschäft also die
bildschirmaufnahme und meine tonaufnahme
und so nicht dass uns genau das gleiche
passiert was mir letztens schon mal
passiert war da habe ich nicht so lange
aufgenommen dass alle dateien plötzlich
fehlerhaft waren
ich finde es echt crazy also ich weiß
natürlich die ich habe wenig kontakt mit
anderen youtube und wie lange deren
videos zu geben in der aufnahme aber
drei stunden hier gerade minecraft zu
spielen in der höhle und unmengen an
smaragde bz was mag da haben wir ja
nicht mal bisher aber an menge an kohle
eisen gold und diamanten sich zu holen
das ist schon brutal und das geht auch
in der substanz gamma kurzfristig waren
sie meine apple wartezimmer gesagt
stehen sie mal bitte auf bewegen sie
sich mal bitte von daher dass man jetzt
nicht ich bewege mich in minecraft meine
lieben freunde und euch noch einmal eine
allerletzte teil müsse heute wie wir
jetzt endlich nach hause laufen
[Musik]
und da sehen wir auch schon wieder
unsere insel meine lieben freunde ich
freue mich total dass wir wieder zu
hause sind und jetzt können wir uns auch
entlädt auf das heutige video thema
konzentrieren nämlich die zahlreichen
tipps die er mir immer unten in die
kommentare schreibt ich packe man brot
mal ganz kurz hier vorne den richtigen
steg haben wir leider nicht mehr weil er
jetzt zur brücke geworden wurde
erstmalig habe eine menge gold
strohballen das feuchte grab mit ge
sagen ich hab auch ne menge gold um mal
kurz zu schließen ich habe allerdings
auch eine menge strohballen mitgenommen
um einfach auf einen kommentar abzugeben
beziehungsweise um auf einen kommentar
zu hören der mir geschrieben wurde und
zwar kann ich diese strohballen wohl
ziemlich gut fürs trading nutzen mit den
pitchern hier und da kann ich zum
beispiel mit ihm hier irgendwie brot
handeln oder irgendwie so keine ahnung
was auf jeden fall einig dass deswegen
mal mitgenommen
ich habe auch hinten noch meine kiste
geblutet und so weiter und so fort und
was ich auch jetzt direkt mal machen
werde ist hier vorne die erde ab und
sieht nicht schön aus und das hat auch
nicht geklappt also das was ihm dann die
kommentare geschrieben aber das hat
nicht so richtig funktioniert dies aber
auch nicht weiter schlimm denn ich
brauche den platz nach vorne auch um mir
mal ganz kurz eben 1 2 3 4 5 6 und
bambus zu nehmen das wird nämlich auch
unten in die kommentare geschrieben und
zwar kann ich derzeit vor ort so
rüberkommt wird also der boss abo und
guckt sogar sein ganzes dorf so ein
bisschen wer hier so auf die insel kommt
und wenn ich mal schauen punkt der ihnen
wenn du jetzt hier überläuft na gut also
wir konzentrieren uns auf die kommentare
meine lieben freunde und zwar packe ich
erstmal hier ganz kurz das rennen nicht
benötigen ein bisschen platz um das zu
machen was mir geschrieben wurde ihr
habt gerade hier schon eingeblendet
gesehen es handelt sich um ein
bambus gerüst und dieses bambus gerüst
kann man eigentlich ganz gut nehmen wenn
man beispiel auch sechs stück kriege ich
sogar aus da kann ich mir richtig viele
bauen das kann man ganz gut benutzen
wenn man irgendwie großprojekte baut wie
beispielsweise führt das schwert was
wirklich sehr geil aussieht da fällt mir
das ganz gut benutzen können um halt
einfach hoch und runter zu klettern die
sonne ja wieso ein gerüst wie so eine
fassade
ich hab mir allerdings gedacht die
stellt das hier das ist ganz cool aus so
als tisch weil das so ein bisschen den
birken holz falltüren hier so ein
bisschen ähnelt dann haben wir so einen
tisch wurde an seinem tisch und so ein
schirm woods und tisch dann befestigt
ist es gibt ja auch ziemlich oft
irgendwie in urlauben dann irgendwo hier
auf mallorca oder keine ahnung was was
wir allerdings als nächstes direkt
machen ihr seht schon freuen ich habe
direkt dem turbo eingeschaltet ist ein
lesepult vor einen villiger stellen das
wird auch und in die kommentare
geschrieben das lesepult haben wir hier
vorne drin perfekt wir können auch mal
direkt die fichtenholz fall turnier
nehmen und hier haben wir auch noch
welche drin den lapislazuli packt ich
mal eben hier vorne rein man kann ich
mir nämlich hier vorne auch direkt mal
wieder das mitnehmen eingepackt hat
nämlich die hacke und die händen zu
unserer farm hin packen das habe ich
vorhin vergessen die sache ist
allerdings dass wir das lesepult erstmal
benötigen weil
[Musik]
die da hinten kinder kriegen aber trinks
nicht hin wahrscheinlich weil wir keine
betten mehr haben ist aber auch egal
ich werde hier vorne erst mal ganz kurz
die hacke reinpacken und wir haben ein
wilder das ist er hier der hat noch
keinen beruf das heißt ich werde jetzt
vor ihm einfach mal das lesepult die du
musst schon dahin dann auch gehen
komm runter von der piste
stimmt ich gehe mal ganz kurz schlafen
du bist morgen damit lesepult immer noch
oben drauf ist aber auch egal denn wir
werden uns erst mal ganz kurz hier um
kümmern denn das ist finde ich sie ein
bisschen unsauber aus dass man hier halt
das grab sieht deswegen wollte ich hier
12 hinsetzen und darauf dann die
falltüren so dass das hier so ein
bisschen china aus nun auf der anderen
seite das hat mich noch viel mehr
getriggert denn hier sieht man den
gesandten runter und dass sie zwar nicht
so schön und deswegen die beiden abbauen
den sandweg zack zack und hier
die letzte brauchen wir nicht immer ganz
gut weg und hier zack zack
so sieht das auf jeden fall deutlich
besser aus ich gehe mal ganz kurz eben
schlafen und dann schauen wir am
nächsten tag auch direkt ob der wille da
nebenan sein lesepult nummer zu einmal
ganz kurz platz machen wie der
einstiegspunkt gesetze ich freue mich
ich bin wirklich wieder richtig zu hause
angekommen und falls ich jetzt sterben
sollte hat sich auf jeden fall ja nicht
gelohnt ich habe 32 level aber dann
sportlich zumindest wieder hier also wir
schauen uns mal ganz kurz an ob der
nebenan den sonst brauche ich nicht mal
ganz dahin wir schauen mal ob er hier
sehen berufe lesepult bzw bibliothekar
angenommen hat ich weiß nicht wo der ist
die beiden verstehen sich ganz gut das
ist ja doch oder sagte bibliothekar und
mit dem können wir jetzt handeln wenn
wir das papier nehmen das heißt wir
brauchen den mit dem handeln wir jetzt
nicht
das wurde nämlich geschrieben ich soll
so lange dem blog dahin setzen glück des
meeres wo ich in die scheiße ich soll so
auf das lesepult abbauen und wieder
hinsetzen bis er entweder unendlichkeit
oder ein reparatur buch für mich hat das
ist nämlich sehr sehr sehr sehr wichtig
denn das bekomme ich nur durch komm
runter hier ja bei ich ich brauche
bibliothekar egal machen wir nachher
ich konzentriere mich erstmal noch auf
weitere sachen die mir geschrieben
wurden das kann ich erst mal hier
abhaken er da habe ich abgebaut das habe
ich gemacht das habe ich gemacht
man muss zum beruf machen habe ich auch
schon gemacht die fichtenholz stufen
unter den brücken beginn habe ich auch
schon ganz ich wollte noch den weg ein
breiter machen das wollte ich nämlich
hier machen
ich finde dass das ein bisschen billig
aussieht wenn man hier so rumläuft dann
hier ich wollte es so machen dass wir
hier ein bisschen mehr platz haben
genauso wie hier vorne bei dem übergang
ich kann auch bei luna wieder in seiner
hundehütte sätzen der zuvor noch die
ganze zeit in den brötchen rum
beziehungsweise blut sollte auch
eigentlich mal ein bisschen verrottetes
fleisch bekommen so kann man mit raus
hier nur ein mal mitgelaufen hier bitte
ganz
[Musik]
luke kommt
gelaufen mitgelaufen jetzt gibt's und
jetzt schieben wir also ganz entspannt
seine hütte freut sich wieder da zu sein
ja ich fand es auch schön und seinen
kleinen ausflug
ich möchte das verrottete fleisch das
ganze gar nicht schmeckt einfach
trotzdem da rein
das wahrzeichen holzboote packen wir
hier vorne wieder hin ich fand's
wirklich sehr sehr geil diese ganze
reise die wir heute hatten und werde
mich allerdings jetzt erst mal ganz kurz
darauf konzentrieren dass ich hier erst
mal noch ein bisschen sachen rein packe
hier vorne zum beispiel ein bisschen was
mal beraten und hier vorne das gold erst
mal rein
ich habe ganz ganz ganz ganz viele items
mitgenommen ganz ganz viel eisen ganz
ganz viel gold und so weiter und so fort
davon benötigen wir erstmal gar nichts
bis auf die ganzen kohleblöcke denn ich
kann ja mit ihm hier kohle traden da
seht ihr schon er hat sogar die
verringerte angebote für mich waren
daher erstmal mit ihm hier ne menge
traden bis er das nicht mehr am start
hat das ist nämlich jetzt gerade schon
der fall und jetzt gehen wir nach
nebenan und traden jetzt einfach mal mit
dem rüstungs schmid und mit unserem ich
weiß gar nicht wie der andere heißt
schauen wir mal eben ganz kurz irgendwie
aufwertung der rüstung schmithals
vereine der hat keine kohle am start hat
er programm statt er auch hier von den
nemesis hier vorne die haben gar nichts
hier irgendwie aber er hat auf jeden
fall kohle trails am start und genau
dafür habe ich die ganze kohle
mitgenommen sodass wir mit den jungs
hier gut handeln können so hier vorne
noch mal eben was rein zeigt jetzt aber
keine kohle mehr allerdings seht ihr
schon der blue
er entwickelt sich gerade er wird warum
kommst riss plötzlich nicht gar nichts
von anfang nicht einfach so mit ihm dass
er sich freut
ein bisschen boden das gebe ich mir
jetzt wieder sehr gut hast du hier vorne
wieder kohle trades im staat hat er noch
nicht hat denn niemand anderes sehen die
kohle trades oder so der hier hat auch
nichts er gibt mir nur brüstung
er hat auch noch rüstung kann ich aber
eigentlich ganz gut gebrauchen also ich
wollte gerne mal ein bisschen mehr
traden so dass ich mit den leuten ja
auch mal ein bisschen cooler bin und
dass sie sich auch ein bisschen freuen
von daher den rest der brüstung den
brauch jetzt tatsächlich erst mal nicht
denn schmeiße ich jetzt einfach mal hier
rein und die sache ist auch dass wenn
ich mehrmals mit einer person traded
dass sie dann den beruf behalten auch
wenn ich denen jetzt theoretisch die
blöcke hier abbauen
also ich möchte trotzdem noch ein
bisschen kohle haben er hat gar nichts
mehr davon am start
hier vorne ist niemand drin ich weiß gar
nicht warum hier niemand einschläft oder
nichts daran macht das ist so schön das
haus und hier ist auch keiner drin wo
ist denn unser bibliothekar wenn man den
mal brauch ich hab hier vorne extra das
lesepult hingestellt ich glaube ich
nehme es doch nochmal ganz kurze weg und
werde jetzt mal schauen ob der hier
irgendwie rüber gelaufen ist oder so das
wäre auch noch mal interessant zu wissen
wir können uns allerdings noch ein
bisschen weiter auf die kommentare
konzert training wurden hier vorne sind
die drin
das sind bauen aber die haben auch kohle
trader das ist ja unfassbar wir können
so viel kohle heute vertreten ich glaube
das ist gerade die längste passage im
kompletten projekt wo ich das ganze hand
gelassen habe allerdings freue ich mich
einfach so wieder zu hause zu sein und
einfach wir so ein bisschen rum zu
traden und einfach mal wieder ein
bisschen zu kommentieren ich habe noch
gar nicht so richtig kommentiert ich
neben seit 3 mehr als drei stunden auf
und habe noch nichts richtig kommentiert
heute allerdings müssen solche folgen
auch mal sein ich weiß nicht ob ich die
folge die große teiles folgen oder keine
ahnung was heute noch passieren wird und
was wir noch hinkriegen allerdings haben
wir schon ganz ganz viel kohle vertreter
die haben 35 level
wir haben 52 zumal es läuft auf jeden
fall sehr sehr sehr sehr gut die sache
ist allerdings was ich ja gerade schon
gesagt habe ich möchte mich noch ein
bisschen mehr auf die kommentare heute
konzentrieren und was mir da unter
anderem auch geschrieben wurde war luca
tui könnte unter wasser sein
das liegt einfach daran dass tui nicht
schwimmen kann und wenn er einmal unter
wasser ist
kommt er nicht so schnell wieder hoch
was so richtig stumpf ist allerdings
würde ich sagen dass wir deswegen mal
ganz kurz eben noch mal mit ihm kohle
traden so dass wir ein paar mehr als
marke noch bekommen sagt jetzt hat er
den schritt sogar nicht mal mehr am
start und hier dies mag da rein und
jetzt schwimmen wir mal eben ganz kurzem
unsere komplette insel rum um zu gucken
ob sich irgendwo unser zweiter shui hier
unter wasser befindet
[Musik]
ok und einmal komplett um eine insel rom
geschwommen
ich weiß nicht ob du irgendwo weiter
weggelaufen ist allerdings war da unten
jetzt erst mal niemand von daher können
wir uns erst mal noch mal ganz kurz
darauf konzentrieren hier wenn eventuell
ein williger dem beruf lesepult bzw
bibliothekar zugeben ich glaube
allerdings dass er sich jetzt schon in
anderen beruf gesucht hat weil es gibt
keinen villiger hier mehr ohne beruf ich
weiß nicht woran das liegt wir können
allerdings erstmal hier hat jeder beruf
warum ist denn niemand warum wir den
niemand bibliothekar werden
[Musik]
so ich hab ich ja gerade mal ganz kurz
eingeblendet da ich noch mal eine menge
items sortiert habe plus auch normale
menge gehandelt habe ich hab jetzt
mittlerweile schon 43 marktlücke
das heißt 43 x 9 smaragde plus noch mal
hier 20 mal vorne hat die trails so kann
nicht mehr am start mit der kohle mir
weder allerdings schon unten ich habe
mir einige schreien ziegel gemacht denn
das auch noch auf meiner liste stand für
heute das ist irgendwie teils time labs
folge heute teilt insel reparatur teils
auch noch kommentare was mir allerdings
nicht geschrieben wurde sondern was ich
mir gedacht habe war dass das hier
wahrscheinlich deutlich schöner aussieht
wenn ich das hier einfach durchgängig
machen und hier nicht so ein ganz
kleines stückchen von dem weg noch zu
sehen ist das fand ich ein bisschen
besser und was ich mir dann auch noch
gedacht hatte war hier vorne bei der
zauberinsel die er teilweise wirklich
kritisiert wird von wegen die sieht gar
nicht so schön aus ich finde ich sehr
schön muss ich ganz klar sagen
allerdings ist die halt nicht mit dem
boden verbunden und das hab ich mir
gedacht mach' ich noch mal eben du hier
vorne kommst wieder weg zack zack zack
zack
und das machen wir jetzt einfach auf
jeder seite mal so ein bisschen denn wir
haben ja jede insel so ein bisschen mit
dem boden verbunden okay das schwert
jetzt nicht die willicher insel auch
nicht so richtig eigentlich gar keine
insel mit dem boden verbunden
aber ich finde hier gehört sich das so
sieht die zauberinsel jetzt auf jeden
fall von unten aus und sie es überall
auf jeden fall verbunden mit dem boden
das heißt das haben wir auch von der
liste jetzt schon fertig ich schaue noch
mal ganz kurz was wir auch noch
geschrieben wurde und zwar dass das eine
bienenstock den ich ja in der letzten
folge entdeckt habe dort ganz hinten
irgendwo beim blumio dass ich den
abbauen kann was ich aber mal ganz kurz
machen wollte waren und ich weiß ich
muss das schaf noch holen ihr müsst mir
nicht in die kommentare schreiben
in jeder folge es tut mir auch leid das
hat mir unter anderem jahr frank
geschrieben allerdings mittlerweile
eigentlich auch jeder
von daher ganz kurz an alle die info das
schaf was ich dorthin befindet im
winzerdorf das wird kommen so bald wie
die
der insel hier vorne machen und das wird
demnächst auf jeden fall der fall sein
die sache sei allerdings hab ich euch ja
grad schon eingeblendet der bienenstock
den müssen wir wohl mit einer
behutsamkeit sache abbauen und da haben
wir ja beispielsweise dass wir das heißt
beispielsweise wir haben nur die gold
spitzhacke und wir brauchen dafür noch
ein lagerfeuer das habe ich unten in
meiner kiste auf jeden fall drin
das müssen wir nämlich unter dem
bienenstock setzen so dass die bienen
nicht am arsch ich nehme schon wieder
eine stunde auf was ein wunderschöner
morgen erwartet uns hier in unserer
kleinen süßen minecraft welt ich hoffe
zum letzten mal in der heutigen ja komm
mit wir werden uns jetzt in richtung
blumen million bewegen denn dort befand
sich ja einen bienen nest bzw den
bienenstock dienen aber ich habe noch
keine ahnung wie das ding genau heißt
deswegen habe ich mir gedacht beziehen
wollen wir auch den kommentar geschenkt
wir nehmen jetzt einfach mal mit wir
können es dann auf unsere insel setzen
oder vielleicht oder viel besser auf die
tiere insel allerdings erst mal bei uns
auf die insel falls das überhaupt
klappen sollte mit dem römer
transportieren hier vorne die villa noch
gibt das wird bald fertig die sache ist
allerdings dass ich noch nicht weiß ob
das richtig klappen will also ich hab
alles mit dabei ist und ich habe den
gold spitzhacken mit behutsamkeit ich
habe auch ein lagerfeuer mit dabei was
ja dann darunter setzen soll so dass
diese bienen nicht ausrasten
ich hab das er hat zweimal bisher
abgebaut und dem kompletten projekt
bisher und da wurde ich beide male
komplett attackiert und so eine
situation habe ich nicht nochmal
riesigen bock drauf deswegen euch jetzt
mal eine ganz kurze time dazu bis ich da
bin
[Musik]
und da sind wir vorne auch schon
angekommen ich werde das schwein einfach
mal ganz kurz hier drin lassen bevor wir
das hier noch irgendwie verlieren
sollten oder so zu eine ganz dumme idee
den mitzunehmen
allerdings sind wir glaube ich in der
folge wo wir das blumen blumen dinge
sage ich schon wo wir dass bienen das
entdeckt haben sind wir glaube ich hier
her gelaufen
ich meine das war da oben irgendwo und
dann habe ich das eher abgebaut und bin
hier irgendwo zurück gelaufen weil ich
ja dann gestochen wurde von der biene
ich weiß allerdings dass wir auch ein
zweites hat das ist nämlich hier perfekt
und wir sehen auch schon wir sehen
eigentlich gar nix also ich brauche da
gar nichts sagen gibt überhaupt keine
ahnung von was ich setze sich ein
lagerfeuer drunter es geht auf jeden
fall nicht durch den block durch oder
geht es dadurch ich habe also ich gehe
hier nehmen
[Musik]
wir haben wir haben es ihr wisst ja dass
sich ein riesiger fan bin von den
verschiedenen blumen in minecraft und
ich finde immer wieder extrem
faszinierend wie schön diese ganzen
dinge sind wir haben hier fordert das
schwein im brötchen 17 ich möchte
allerdings einmal ganz kurz die alles
ein bisschen entdecken guckt euch mal
wie viele blumen wir sind wenn wir die
tiere insel machen müssen wir auf jeden
fall noch eine menge blumen holen
und dass wir die dann auch auf die insel
setzen können aber schaut euch mal dran
wie schön das hier einfach alles ist
[Musik]
doch wahnsinn mit den ganzen blumen und
so ich kann mich nie richtig entscheiden
welches mein lieblings biom in minecraft
ist schaut mal hier
die hammer das einfach aus wie ich kann
mich wirklich nicht entscheiden welches
bio mich am wohlsten finden in minecraft
ob das jetzt tatsächlich irgendwie die
savanne ist ob das der ozean ist so wie
wir es haben oder ob das vielleicht auch
wie es wie wir es hier halt haben
solltet ihr gesagt hier in sage ich
schon so ne blumeninsel ist also es ist
wirklich wirklich wundervoll ich werde
gleich wieder zurücklaufen zum scharf
was da vorne ist allerdings einmal ganz
kurz die so ein bisschen rum entdecken
bzw
wir könnten theoretisch auch eigentlich
mal so ein paar blumen mitten in die
benötigen wir ja eh und dann müssen wir
eventuell bei der nächsten folge bzw
wenn wir das machen mit der tier insel
die nicht noch mal hin laufen könnt
haben wir schicken rumlaufen ich nehme
jetzt einfach mal hier sonntag blumen
mit und das ist wirklich wundervoll die
hühnchen müssen wir auch noch mitnehmen
auf unsere insel das hatte ich irgendwie
vergessen hat
[Musik]
er ist nicht hier eigentlich noch ein
zweiter raum herunter oder so dachte ich
jetzt oder so oder ist er noch weiter
unten habe ich es einfach blöd dass hier
oben noch irgendwie ein raum wenn ich
hier rein gehen ehe der handel lockt
gerade die kiste abgebaut eigentlich
müsste hier drunter glaube ich noch im
raum seien aber dass er so typisch dass
wir hier direkt wieder sondern dings für
den kurier schatzkarte ruhe brauche ihn
nicht habe ich eh schon jeder brauche
ich befehle
hey das ist ja wahnsinn wie viele wie
von diesen wracks finden
also ich weiß wahrscheinlich haben ganz
viele irgendwie tausende mehr wracks
gefunden und so das ist überhaupt nicht
krass was bei mir hier abgeht aber ich
finde es immer wieder
crazy hier vorne ist doch meistens auch
noch irgendwie eine kiste drin oder irre
ich mich da gerade aber er wird
irgendwann die kommentare geschrieben
dass pro dings wirklich immer drei
kisten am start sind ich weiß nur gerade
nicht weil hier alles irgendwie zu
[Musik]
also da brauche ich wirklich gar nichts
raus ich nehme die karotten mit so ein
bisschen was sind es nicht verkehrt und
schwarzpulver vielleicht auch noch mal
eben lasse ich mir das holz da wird
dürfen allerdings gar nicht langer zeit
für den von euch eine ganz kurze zeit
zurück zu balu laufe die jungs weise wir
haben eine schatzkarte
[Musik]
wir haben den schatz gefunden freunde er
befindet sich hier vorne und dorthin
befindet sich sogar diamanten okay das
ist der absolute oberklasse da freue ich
mich gerade sehr sehr sehr sehr darüber
wir brauchen die kiste einfach mal
direkt ab ich geh mal ganz kurz nach
oben und lagen kurz ein bisschen luft
ein und die blume von dem wir am
wenigsten haben nur nicht in der rosat
tulpe die schmelze ich mal ganz kurz weg
um mich hier das wichtigste mitzunehmen
diamanten habe ich jetzt noch nicht
eingesammelt den goldbarren brauche ich
auch nicht gebraten den kabeljau wobei
euch dann sowas hat es mich auch schon
ganz viel dann kann ich vielleicht doch
dass die gold und in gebracht habe ich
auch noch mitnehmen zum traden also man
ganz schnell wieder auftauchen und jetzt
eine ganz kurze einem netz das ist
einfach die grosse tat folgen
ihr ahnt auch nicht wie sich diese
schatzkarte war
guckt euch das mal an unten ich habe
noch nie gegen die es ihnen die größer
als alle anderen bisher
und da sind wir wieder zu hause
angekommen meine lieben freunde das
schwein werde ich mal ganz gut zum
mitnehmen und dementsprechend das boot
hier abbauen
das müssen wir dann auch ganz kurz auch
mitnehmen denn das will ich auf die
andere seite setzen das sieht auf jeden
fall schon deutlich besser aus hier
vorne und wir können jetzt auch direkt
das ganze mit dem bienenstock bedienen
lässt einfach mal eben testen
ich weiß nicht so richtig wo ich es hin
setzen soll am besten halt dann
irgendein baum da oben
ich dachte der cloud meine brücke
zusammenarbeit nur erde in der hand am
besten wäre es wenn ich irgendwo
hinsetzen wo es nicht stört also
irgendwo wo ich nicht so häufig langen
laufe also vielleicht irgendwie hier
vorne oder so klappt das denn jetzt
[Musik]
wir betrachten das so das wollte ich
nicht sind jetzt bieten oder nicht ich
weiß es nicht ich lasse das erst mal
erschien um gott ich bin so stolz auf
dieses schwer portal die sache ist
allerdings dass wir schon wieder sehen
dass die sonne untergeht freunde ich bin
bei meiner zweiten aufnahmen jetzt
gerade schon bei eineinhalb stunden also
insgesamt ca
fast vier stunden jetzt mittlerweile in
der aufnahme ich musste die ganze zeit
auch zwischen mit augentropfen benutzen
weil ich nicht so einfach auf den
bildschirm gucken kann
die sich aber eben ganz kurz die noch
ein paar items und ich hoffe es gab noch
nie eine folge die so lange in der
aufnahme ging es ist wirklich einfach
die große teile maps folge also mal ganz
kurz die sachen hier sichern die eisen
klumpp mache ich mal eben zu eisenbach
und ich blende euch nochmal ganz kurze
time lab sein in der ich gleich schlafen
gehe und in der ich auch meine lieben
freunde und das wird sich auch gewünscht
endlich mal die kisten sortierung mache
den applaus habe ich mir wirklich
verdient das wird echt nicht spaßig
gleich deswegen dafür euch halt auch die
time letzten wochen die kommen da
geschrieben luca keine stelle ich mir
voll cool vor ort listen sortierung und
zweitens sofort wird es nicht sein
ich werde einfach jetzt die ganzen
sachen nehmen und darüber räume in die
kisten kripp also time labs die letzte
für heute knapp mit den bienen freut
mich
deswegen davon existiert auch noch ne
super krass wie hoch die auf ihm egal
ich darf ihn nicht ablenken lassen teilt
es weiter ich habe noch mal ganz kurz
um euch das zu zeigen hier schon mal
angefangen hier fordern soll holz reihen
hier vorne er so stein hier hinten was
man halt über wo man doch eher sehr
schlecht dran kommt einfach sachen die
ich wirklich nicht häufig brauche also
so tulpen und sonnencremes hier vorne
wenig sand und so erde drin haben das
werde ich aber gleich mal nicht erklären
[Musik]
der zurück
mit dem handeln beziehungsweise was hat
er so für sachen am start schwarzen
farbstoff roten webel höhe hellblauen
türkisen und schwarzpulver davon bei
euch auf jeden fall eigentlich erst mal
gar nichts der bleibt allerdings jetzt
erst für ein paar folgen hier also der
nächsten folge sind überall wieder am
start
ich kann euch schon mal ein fortschritt
so ein bisschen zeigen hier die ganzen
holz sachen da kommt auch noch das
gerüst rein
die truhe kommt da rein setzlinge und
das war's dann habe ich hier vorne
die ganze unwichtige sachen drin also
ein bisschen natur shit hier vorne habe
ich den ganzen wolle ich haben schon
recht viel wolle am start und hier vorne
habe ich so ein bisschen teardrop
beziehungsweise hier so ein bisschen
essen hier vorne habe ich so sachen drin
wo ich wirklich nicht weiß wofür ich die
benötige also klar ich weiß wofür ich im
goldenen apfel brauch oder ein kolben
allerdings benötige ich diese sachen
halt wirklich nahezu nie werkzeuge habe
ich hier drin also ihr seht hier angeln
schwerter weise betten und so weiter und
so fort hier habe ich eine menge drin
ich weiß nicht wofür ich die er braucht
das macht sinn wenn ich ihr das leder
noch mal rein packe die pfeile
behalte ich mal bogen kommt auch hier
vorne zu den sachen mit rein da habe ich
jetzt schon mehrere bögen drin lager
vorher hier vorne laterne kommt mit zur
dekoration wollte ich hier einpacken
herz des meeres habe ich mittlerweile
schon fünf stück brauche ich eigentlich
gar nicht alle aber ich habe da mal eine
ganz ganz ganz ganz kurze alle aller
allerletzte time labs wie ich jetzt auch
noch den rest hierüber packte ihr seht
allerdings auch schon ich habe hier gar
nicht mehr so viel drin dies noch
relativ voll
[Musik]
oh mein gott ich bin endlich fertig und
das ist auch endlich das ende der
heutigen folge meine lieben freunde ich
habe viereinhalb stunden soeben
minecraft ausgenommen werden dass man
von einem halben jahr gesagt hatte ich
den vogel gezeigt das ist wirklich
wahnsinn allerdings seht ihr schon die
kiste slayer das hier ist leer die
fässer sind alle leer wir haben hier
vorne die wertvollen kisstel er die
krims krams kisten sind alle leer
die öfen sind leer ich habe auch keine
kohle mehr weil ich alles fairtrade habe
ihr seht unten ich habe 42 level jetzt
zu sterben wir auf jeden fall blöd die
kiste kann ich auf jeden fall brauchen
eben abbauen da habe ich nämlich alle
sachen drin gelagert die ich sonst immer
im inventar habe also hier meine
werkzeuge und so weiter und so fort die
kiste kommt dann mal hier vorne in
unsere holztruhe rein ich werde euch mal
ganz gut zeigen was ich mir dabei
gedacht habe und zwar hier die holz tour
mit setzlingen und so weiter und so fort
hier so ein bisschen essen ich habe noch
eine menge essen da hinten in meinem
haus drin und ich habe dort unten ja
auch noch ein paar farben sachen habe
ich so ein bisschen aufgeteilt ich habe
eine menge weizen zubrot verwandelt ich
habe hier sand und kies und erde drin
und hier vorne habe ich die ganzen
werkzeuge drin die ich noch habe hier
oben haben wir dann so ein paar sachen
wie beispielsweise verzauberte bücher
totem der und sterblichkeit eine
schatzkarte seltene sachen wo ich das
allerdings nicht so richtig zuordnen
kann hier kann ich das allerdings so
hatte ich habe ich mich eine menge satt
und den ganzen liederkranz ich habe hier
redstone sachen also die ganzen schienen
tnt und harken und lover etc und hier
habe ich auch so krims krams sachen die
ich nie benutzen werden sehen welche
glasflaschen gegen trank der heilung wo
es nicht mehr dass ich das habe änderten
die man für das ende des projekts
brauchen wir das dann kloster und so
weiter und so fort
das ist die seite hier vorne wenn wir
uns jetzt umdrehen haben wir hier die
ganzen stein sachen
hier haben wir so ein bisschen sachen
die jetzt mit natur zu tun haben aber
uns irgendwie auch nichts bringen also
eichenlaub ezb hier haben wir in sachen
die mit natur zu tun haben und uns etwas
bringen also weizenkörner wir haben hier
weizen bambus was man an pflanzen kann
et cetera pp hier haben wir ganz viele
blumen und dekoration scrum aus der
natur hier vorne haben wir ganz viel
krimskrams man braucht immer eine
krimskrams kisten nicht in minecraft und
ich weiß einfach nicht wo ich die ganzen
sachen hierhin packen soll also eine
menge wolle ist wie beispielsweise
vorhanden und hier oben haben wir dann
die ganzen wertvollen sachen also hier
die diamanten wir haben hier redstone
die ganz vielen smaragd blöcke wo wir
demnächst wirklich mitreden müssen und
so wie gold eisen die cvp und auch die
nette rief platten von denen wir leider
erst eine haben hier vorne habe ich ein
bisschen glas und auch so ein krims
krams der hier unten nicht mehr mit
reingepasst hat und hier oben rechts
habe ich sogar noch um fast frei also
wir haben wirklich wirklich jetzt
endlich mal alles so ein bisschen
sortiert und da bin ich auch sehr sehr
sehr sehr froh darüber
es war die längste folge und generell
das längste video das ich je in meiner
kompletten zehnjährigen bitten wir fast
zehnjährigen youtube laufbahn bisher
aufgenommen habe ihr seht schon die
sonne da hinten geht unter und an der
stelle würde ich dir heute die episode
auch beenden meine lieben freunde wenn
es euch gefallen hat spam den like
button nach oben ich würde schon einmal
freuen es war die große time labs folge
vielleicht ist das der video auch gar
nicht so lang geworden weil ich so viel
mit timeless gearbeitet habe aber ich
habe wirklich viereinhalb schon
aufgenommen es ist unfassbar ich hab ich
ganz so lieb wie gehört sagt lasten
daumen hoch und ein video hier da
abonniert main kanal falls doch kein
teil der lupo seite und klickt auf die
glocke wenn ihr demnächst neue videos
nicht verpassen wollte am morgen geht es
weiter 20 uhr neue folge minecraft mit
luca
ciao
[Musik]